so we understand that never before has
there been another Tamil film released
in so many theaters in the US on how
much does it mean to you it means a lot
and because I started as a child actor
then went into a plea and waited for
myself to grow make him something and I
never wonder I'm a reluctant actor I
came back to become a technician I was a
dance choreographer I have started
learning dance very early I was dancer
system than a choreographer then an
assistant director then I co-wrote some
scripts all these things happened before
20 so that's a great opportunity it's
learning and getting paid and getting
famous in those but not famous enough if
you compare today but if I was a nobody
and people were so kind to me they sort
of thought that I had it when even I
didn't think I have some kind of a
talent worthy of exhibition but they
kept goading me into going to the and
these were strangers who became friends
and then my brothers and some of them my
father figures yeah my mentor mr. K
Balachander picked me up from nowhere
and gave me small bit role and full
number one it's like mr. Danny day-lewis
doing a role in Gandhi you don't even
notice him and then few years later
there's mr. Danny day-lewis it's like
that I I was a nobody in the film
second Fulham I had a very important
role third I was promoted to lead man
fourth and I was ready to play any role
in his film sometimes I just walk
through in a character I've done 36
films with it with my mentor which
itself is a record
you